Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. The topic for this episode is climate change. And just a reminder before we get started, if you have any ideas for us, questions or comments, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-D-org. Polar vortexes, melting glaciers, historic flooding, and devastating wildfires, people are now ranking climate change as one of the world's top threats alongside ISIS and cyber attacks.
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会每两周一期的播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。本期节目的主题是气候变化。在开始之前提醒大家，如果您有任何想法、问题或建议，请发送电子邮件至 K-Luna@APA.org。即 K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。极地涡旋、冰川融化、历史性洪水和毁灭性的野火，人们现在将气候变化与“伊斯兰国”和网络攻击并列为全球最严重的威胁之一。
That's according to a new Pew Research Center poll. As we grapple with the warming world and increasingly unstable weather, our mental health is at risk. Many scientists predict that stress, anxiety, depression, and PTSD will increase as climate change's physical impacts accelerate. Is there anything we can do to mitigate the mental health risks of climate change? Our guest is Dr. Susan Clayton, a professor of psychology and environment. studies at the College of Worcester. Welcome, Dr. Clayton. Thank you, Caitlin. I want to start off by talking about a book you co-edited called Psychology and Climate Change, Human Perceptions, Impacts, and Responses. How can psychology contribute to our understanding of climate change? I think that psychology is really
这是皮尤研究中心一项最新民意调查的结果。当我们努力应对变暖的世界和日益不稳定的天气时，我们的心理健康正面临风险。许多科学家预测，随着气候变化对物理环境的影响加速，压力、焦虑、抑郁和创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）将会增加。我们能做些什么来减轻气候变化带来的心理健康风险吗？我们的嘉宾是伍斯特学院心理学与环境研究教授苏珊·克莱顿博士。欢迎您，克莱顿博士。谢谢你，凯特琳。我想先谈谈您共同编辑的一本书，书名是《心理学与气候变化：人类的感知、影响与应对》。心理学如何有助于我们理解气候变化？我认为心理学确实
important to climate change through both our set of research skills and tools, as well as our focus on an individual level. As psychologists, we really conceptualize, and prioritize individual well-being in a very broad way, more, I think, than any other discipline. And we also emphasize individual behavior and influences on individual behavior, which is very important to, you know, to addressing climate change, both through policy preferences as well as through affecting individual behavioral choices. Do you think there's enough awareness about the mental health risks associated climate change? I mean, we often think of the physical elements, but what would be?
对气候变化非常重要，这不仅得益于我们的一系列研究技能和工具，还得益于我们对个人层面的关注。作为心理学家，我们确实以一种非常广泛的方式概念化并优先考虑个人福祉，我认为这比任何其他学科都要深入。我们还强调个人行为以及对个人行为的影响，这对于解决气候变化问题非常重要，无论是通过政策偏好还是通过影响个人的行为选择。你认为人们对气候变化相关的心理健康风险有足够的认识吗？我的意思是，我们通常会想到物理层面的因素，但什么是？
mental health? No, I really think there hasn't been enough attention to this. And you have this sort of trajectory with the discussion of climate change that first everybody thought about basically polar bears and on their little melting ice flows. We have progressed a little bit to start thinking more about human impacts of climate change. But I don't think the impacts on mental health are something that very many people are aware of. And obviously it's important for people to be to be aware because as I mentioned in the intro, stress, anxiety, PTSD are all risks people face in addition to maybe like losing homes and devastating wildfires or flooding and things like that. So do you think we're at a point now where
心理健康？不，我真的认为对此关注不够。关于气候变化的讨论有一个轨迹，起初每个人基本上想到的都是北极熊和它们融化的小冰块。我们已经取得了一些进展，开始更多地思考气候变化对人类的影响。但我认为，气候变化对心理健康的影响并没有被很多人意识到。显然，人们意识到这一点很重要，因为正如我在开场白中提到的，除了可能失去家园、遭遇毁灭性野火或洪水等情况外，压力、焦虑、创伤后应激障碍都是人们面临的风险。那么，你认为我们现在是否处于一个
awareness is increasing or by doing interviews like this, it will increase or do it, you know, as you write your books as you do your studies? I think it is. Certainly there seems to be, you know, more media attention. And I certainly hope that there's increasing attention and partly because we are getting more and more evidence, so we don't have to just speculate we can start to look at what the research is showing. Yeah, and for people who've already been affected by a climate-related natural disaster, like wildfires we saw in California in the fall or coastal flooding, what are some of the psychological symptoms people experience after an event like that?
意识正在提高的阶段？或者通过做这样的采访，或者当你写书、做研究时，这种意识会提高吗？我想是的。当然，媒体的关注似乎更多了。我当然希望这种关注能不断增加，部分原因是我们要获得越来越多的证据，所以我们不必仅仅进行推测，我们可以开始审视研究显示了什么。是的，对于那些已经受到气候相关自然灾害影响的人，比如我们在秋季看到的加州野火或沿海洪水，人们在经历这样的事件后会有哪些心理症状？
There's definitely impacts on your mental health, you know, even though we've only recently started thinking about climate change impacts. There have been natural disasters forever, and they've been studied for some time. So we know that they tend to lead to an increase in things like post-traumatic stress disorder, depression, and things you might not be as aware of, like, substance abuse. And what about something maybe less, a little less acute, but still nonetheless important, maybe feelings of hopelessness, feelings of loss. Do those increase in the wake of a natural disaster as people try to recover?
这对心理健康肯定有影响，你知道，尽管我们最近才开始考虑气候变化的影响。自然灾害一直存在，并且已经被研究了一段时间。所以我们知道，它们往往会导致创伤后应激障碍、抑郁症等问题的增加，以及一些你可能不太注意到的问题，比如药物滥用。那么，一些可能不那么急性但同样重要的问题呢，比如绝望感、失落感？当人们试图从自然灾害中恢复时，这些感觉会增加吗？
Yes, people often use the term grief to describe the responses. of people who have experienced it. There's a sadness associated with what is lost, which may be your home, which, of course, is extremely psychologically important, your community, your, you know, very practical impacts on your economic well-being. And another impact of these kinds of natural disasters is often an increase on social tensions. So research has shown increases in things like domestic violence, too. Wow.
是的，人们经常用“悲伤”这个词来描述经历过这些的人的反应。与失去的东西相关的悲伤，这可能是你的家——当然，这在心理上极其重要——你的社区，或者你经济福祉方面非常实际的影响。这类自然灾害的另一个影响通常是社会紧张局势的加剧。因此，研究表明家庭暴力等问题也有所增加。哇。
So it can really have a ripple effect beyond the initial loss of dealing with. with loss of a home or, you know, injuries, that kind of thing. Absolutely. Yeah. And so you've been involved in a lot of APA's work about the application of psychology to climate change. We had a task force on the interface between psychology and global climate change that published report almost 10 years ago back in 2009. And also APA's reports in collaboration with Eco America that were published in 2014 and 17.
所以它确实会产生连锁反应，超越了处理失去家园或受伤等最初的损失。绝对是这样。是的。所以你一直参与美国心理学会（APA）关于心理学在气候变化中应用的许多工作。我们有一个关于心理学与全球气候变化之间联系的工作组，在近10年前的2009年发布了一份报告。还有APA与Eco America合作的报告，分别于2014年和2017年发布。
So you've been involved in this space for quite a while and also with your work at the college. Yes. Yeah. Can you talk a little bit about what got you interested? in environmental studies and psychology? Oh, sure. Well, it's a long story I'll try to sort of summarize. I'm trained as a social psychologist,
所以你在这个领域已经工作了很长一段时间，在学院的工作也是如此。是的。你能谈谈是什么让你对环境研究和心理学感兴趣吗？哦，当然。这是一个很长的故事，我会试着总结一下。我受过社会心理学家的训练，
and I've always been interested in people's reactions to social issues, you know, group identity, those kinds of things. And I also care about the environment. And I started to notice just through my informal observations and my readings that, you know, the natural environment was a really important source of experience for people, and it was one that had both meaning to them as individuals and also had sort of social significance. And a lot of parents, for example, are very deliberate about introducing their children to
我一直对人们对社会问题的反应感兴趣，比如群体认同等等。我也关心环境。我开始通过非正式的观察和阅读注意到，自然环境确实是人们体验的一个非常重要的来源，它对个人既有意义，也具有某种社会意义。例如，许多父母在引导孩子接触
the natural world and telling them how we need to take care of the natural world. So I just started to think of the natural environment as a source of psychological influence. And then as attention to climate change got increased, I started to think about the impact of climate change on that sort of psychological as well as social well-being. And what about just even if you're not experiencing something directly like like a climate-related natural disaster, but just watching that constant stream of news coverage about polar ice melting and extreme weather, what does that do to our mental health collectively and for people who are kind of more bystanders in that regard?
自然世界并告诉他们我们需要如何爱护自然世界时，是非常用心的。所以我开始把自然环境看作是一种心理影响的来源。然后，随着对气候变化的关注增加，我开始思考气候变化对那种心理以及社会福祉的影响。那么，即使你没有直接经历像气候相关自然灾害那样的事情，只是看着关于极地冰层融化和极端天气的持续新闻报道，这对我们的集体心理健康以及那些作为旁观者的人有什么影响呢？
Yeah, I think that's a great question because we usually think about the people who are directly influenced by something and what they might be suffering. when it comes to climate change, even people who aren't experiencing the direct impacts are nevertheless facing this big deal thing that some might call an existential challenge. So even though you might not have been individually affected, you might be experiencing certainly an increase in stress, for example. And the APA has their stress in America survey. And the most recent version found, I think, about 50% of people said that climate change was a significant source of stress for them. And of course, we have a lot of stress in our lives, but for some people,
是的，我认为这是一个很好的问题，因为我们通常会考虑那些直接受到影响的人以及他们可能遭受的痛苦。当谈到气候变化时，即使是那些没有经历直接影响的人，也同样面临着这一重大事件，有些人可能会称之为生存挑战。所以，即使你没有受到个人影响，你也可能确实正在经历压力的增加。美国心理学会（APA）有他们的“美国压力调查”。我记得最新版本发现，大约50%的人表示气候变化是他们压力的重要来源。当然，我们的生活中有很多压力，但对一些人来说，
that one additional source of stress might kind of push them to a point where they feel that they can't cope very well. Yeah. How do you, I mean, this feels very far away at some point. Some of these things we're seeing on as we look at, look to, you know, the Arctic and some of these big changes we're seeing on that front. It's easy, probably imagining to feel helpless. I felt that way too when you see all that's going on and you wonder what you can do as an individual. So, How do you stay aware of what's happening without getting overwhelmed by what you're seeing? Yeah, I think a really important problem for people is how to stay optimistic. And certainly optimism is a good thing and optimism is associated with being more resilient to negative events.
那一个额外的压力源可能会把他们推向一个感觉自己无法很好应对的地步。是的。我的意思是，在某种程度上，这感觉非常遥远。当我们看向北极以及我们在那方面看到的一些巨大变化时，我们所看到的一些事情。想象一下感到无助可能很容易。当你看到正在发生的一切，想知道作为个人你能做什么时，我也曾有过这种感觉。那么，你如何在不被所见所闻压垮的情况下保持对正在发生的事情的了解呢？是的，我认为人们面临的一个非常重要的问题是如何保持乐观。当然，乐观是一件好事，乐观与对负面事件更具韧性有关。
I would say two factors are really important. One is to stay informed and think of things that you can do because not. not only will you be maybe addressing the problem, you'll also feel more empowered and you'll have a higher sense of efficacy. And I think that that feeling of helplessness is a real problem. So when people do identify something they can do, that helps avoid that problem. And the second thing would be to to form groups, to form communities with other people because social bonds are so incredibly important to our mental health and also forming these. these groups make us feel more powerful because of course groups can get things accomplished that individuals can't and feel more hopeful and just share information with each other so
我想说有两个因素非常重要。一个是保持知情并思考你能做的事情，因为你不仅可能在解决问题，你还会感到更有力量，并会有更高的效能感。我认为那种无助感是一个真正的问题。所以当人们确实确定了他们能做的事情时，这有助于避免那个问题。第二件事是组建团体，与他人建立社区，因为社会纽带对我们的心理健康非常重要，而且组建这些团体让我们感到更有力量，因为当然，团体可以完成个人无法完成的事情，并感到更有希望，还可以互相分享信息，以便
we can actually be more effective. And I think people can form groups in a variety of different ways depending on how they want to respond to this issue. They can just form communities to kind of inform themselves about the likely impacts of climate change or to talk about their emotional response or they can form communities that become, you know, politically active and try to work within the local community or at a national level to address issues of climate change. And again, hopefully that will have an impact, but from the individual's perspective, it will almost certainly enhance their mental health.
我们实际上可以更有效。我认为人们可以根据他们想要如何应对这个问题，以各种不同的方式组建团体。他们可以仅仅组建社区来了解气候变化的可能影响，或者谈论他们的情绪反应，或者他们可以组建变得在政治上活跃的社区，并尝试在当地社区或国家层面努力解决气候变化问题。同样，希望这会产生影响，但从个人的角度来看，这几乎肯定会改善他们的心理健康。
And what about is individuals? I mean, you're talking about being a collective and making change. But as an individual, is it something as simple things you can do to help with climate change is to make small behavioral changes like, you know, using less plastic silverware or consuming less meat? I mean, what are some of those tangible things people can do in their individual lives? And do they have a big impact? They do. I know that people can think, oh, nothing I can do as an individual will make any difference. But actually, I think, you know, So at some level, only individuals can make a difference through their collective choices. And if enough individuals make choices, it can have a big impact.
那么作为个人呢？我的意思是，你谈到了成为一个集体并做出改变。但作为个人，帮助应对气候变化是否就像做出小的行为改变一样简单，比如少用塑料餐具或少吃肉？我的意思是，人们在个人生活中可以做哪些具体的事情？它们有很大的影响吗？它们确实有。我知道人们可能会想，哦，作为个人我所做的一切都不会有任何改变。但实际上，我认为，在某种程度上，只有个人通过他们的集体选择才能有所作为。如果足够多的个人做出选择，它就会产生巨大的影响。
It's not all just about what organizations and industry does. So one of the most important things you can do as an individual is to try and affect public policy by voting, by calling your government representatives and letting them know that you support pro-environmental policy. the same thing is true for affecting industry. You can have an impact on companies through your consumer choices and you can also contact them and industries are responding to these, you know, to consumer attitudes so you can really make a difference there. But of course, we also want to do things that feel more concrete at a behavioral level. Some of the most
这不仅仅是关于组织和行业做什么。所以作为个人，你能做的最重要的事情之一就是通过投票、致电你的政府代表并让他们知道你支持环保政策来尝试影响公共政策。这对影响行业也是如此。你可以通过你的消费选择对公司产生影响，你也可以联系他们，行业正在对这些消费者态度做出反应，所以你真的可以在那里有所作为。但当然，我们也想做一些在行为层面上感觉更具体的事情。一些最
important things are to find ways to reduce your use of fossil fuels. So if you can afford it, buying a more energy-efficient car or energy-efficient appliances or just not using those things as often. So, you know, if you can walk or take public transportation, I'm a big fan of clothes lines for drying my clothes in the summer because I think that clothes smell good. It's a good way of saving energy. And as you point out, our diet is one of the things that has the biggest impact on the planet.
重要的事情是找到减少化石燃料使用的方法。所以如果你负担得起，购买更节能的汽车或节能电器，或者只是不那么频繁地使用这些东西。所以，如果你能步行或乘坐公共交通工具，我是夏天用晾衣绳晾衣服的忠实粉丝，因为我认为衣服闻起来很香。这是一个节能的好方法。正如你指出的，我们的饮食是对地球影响最大的因素之一。
So if you can cut meat out of your diet or if you don't... don't want to do that, maybe just reduce the amount of meat you eat or move away from so much red meat and towards, you know, the other, the other meats and fish, that's also going to have a big impact on the environment. Absolutely. And who is the most vulnerable to the mental health effects of climate change? Well, there's a variety of ways of thinking about vulnerability. So you can be sort of socially vulnerable. You can of course be geographically vulnerable. So people who are, you know, located in coastal areas or low-lying islands are very vulnerable. You can be financially vulnerable. People who have more financial resources are usually better able to protect themselves
所以如果你能从饮食中戒掉肉，或者如果你不想那样做，也许只是减少你吃的肉量，或者从红肉转向其他肉类和鱼类，这对环境也会有很大的影响。绝对是这样。谁最容易受到气候变化对心理健康影响的伤害？嗯，思考脆弱性有多种方式。所以你可以是社会层面上的脆弱。你当然可以是地理层面上的脆弱。所以那些位于沿海地区或低洼岛屿的人非常脆弱。你可以在经济上脆弱。拥有更多经济资源的人通常比那些资源较少的人更有能力保护自己。
than those who have fewer. But I want to highlight in particular the fact that children are more vulnerable. And of course, they're more vulnerable because they're going to be living with the consequences of what we do now. So they're going to just experience climate change to a greater extent. But also the kinds of effects and events they experience when they're young can have a disproportionate impact. You know, new research by or fairly new research by psychologist is looking at the way that experiencing stress and trauma as a child may have permanent impacts on your sort of cognitive processes and emotional self-regulation, for example, as an adult. High levels of pollution, which can be associated with the climate
但我特别想强调的是，儿童更脆弱。当然，他们更脆弱，因为他们将不得不与我们现在所做行为的后果一起生活。所以他们将更大程度地体验气候变化。而且，他们在年轻时经历的各种影响和事件可能会产生不成比例的影响。你知道，心理学家的一项新研究正在观察儿童时期经历压力和创伤的方式可能会对你成年后的认知过程和情绪自我调节产生永久性影响。高水平的污染，这可能与气候有关，
because we have, you know, higher temperatures lead to higher levels of ground level ozone. higher levels of pollution have effects on our cognitive processes that may, again, have permanent effects into adulthood. And, of course, children can be physiologically damaged more easily at a young age because their body systems aren't all fully developed. For example, they are not as good as regulating their own temperatures, so they might respond more strongly to high levels of heat and so on. Yeah, and talking about children, obviously the Earth's growing population contributes to environmental problems. That's something that's noted and talked about frequently. And some people are deciding not to have children due to climate change or perhaps maybe only having one child, maybe adopting, that kind of thing. What are your thoughts on this?
因为我们有更高的温度导致更高水平的地面臭氧。更高水平的污染对我们的认知过程有影响，这可能再次对成年期产生永久性影响。当然，儿童在年轻时更容易在生理上受到损害，因为他们的身体系统还没有完全发育。例如，他们调节自身温度的能力不如成年人，所以他们可能会对高温等做出更强烈的反应。是的，谈到儿童，显然地球不断增长的人口导致了环境问题。这是经常被提及和讨论的事情。有些人因为气候变化决定不生孩子，或者也许只生一个孩子，也许领养，诸如此类。你对此有什么看法？
Well, it's interesting because people are very, it's like the third rail topic. People get very defensive about talking about the choice to have children. I just recently, as part of a class exercise, had my students distribute a questionnaire that asked people about environmental attitudes and whether they thought families should be encouraged to have no more than two children. And my students reported that, of course,
嗯，这很有趣，因为人们非常……这就像第三轨话题。人们在谈论生育选择时会变得非常防御。我最近作为课堂练习的一部分，让我的学生分发了一份问卷，询问人们对环境的态度，以及他们是否认为应该鼓励家庭生育不超过两个孩子。我的学生报告说，当然，
everybody had positive environmental attitudes, but they were very reluctant to say there should be limits on family size. I think we do need to acknowledge that, you know, more people means more stress on environmental resources. It's just, you know, it's basic physics. Now, so I think that we, let me back up a second. You know, there are all kinds of reasons not to have laws about the number of children people have,
每个人都有积极的环境态度，但他们非常不愿意说应该限制家庭规模。我认为我们确实需要承认，更多的人意味着对环境资源的压力更大。这只是基本物理学。所以我想我们，让我退后一步。你知道，有各种各样的理由不制定关于人们生育孩子数量的法律，
but I think what would be a better approach would be to provide more options that allow people to have the number of children they want and not more than they want. So more federal access to, you know, contraception and also sex education, I think that would go a long way to keeping our population in check. Do you think that will increase as time goes on? And as like you said, children are more vulnerable to the effects of climate change. And as we see what is set in motion to happen to the planet, do you think that this could become more of an issue that's talked about in the media?
但我认为更好的方法是提供更多的选择，让人们能够拥有他们想要的数量的孩子，而不是超过他们想要的数量。所以更多的联邦渠道来获取避孕措施以及性教育，我认为这将对控制我们的人口大有帮助。你认为随着时间的推移，这种情况会增加吗？正如你所说，儿童更容易受到气候变化影响。随着我们看到为地球设定的未来，你认为这会成为媒体上讨论更多的问题吗？
You mean population control? Yeah, population control. I would imagine so. I mean, even if you don't think that there are too many people now, you know, when there are whatever, 7.3 billion, when it gets to 10 billion, you might then think, oh, now there are too many. So I do believe at some point it's going to become more of a topic of discussion than it is now. And one thing when I was researching this topic, I found really interesting and frightening at the same time was basically how the effects of climate change, even if we were to stop all, stop in our tracks, no more emissions. you know, no more population growth, everyone becomes a vegetarian and so forth. Even if we were to do all that right now, the effects would still continue in some ways
你是说人口控制？是的，人口控制。我想会的。我的意思是，即使你不认为现在人太多了，你知道，当有73亿人时，当它达到100亿时，你可能就会想，哦，现在人太多了。所以我确实相信在某个时候，它会比现在成为更多讨论的话题。当我研究这个话题时，我发现了一件既有趣又可怕的事情，基本上是气候变化的后果，即使我们停止一切，停止脚步，不再有排放，
because they've been set in motion from the past. So in your understanding, as a psychologist and environmental scholar, that's pretty, it's pretty frightening, I guess, to know that this, all these changes could still happen. But we were, we would be mitigating future changes, So what are your thoughts on that? I think you're right. And that definitely leads to,
不再有人口增长，每个人都变成素食者等等。即使我们现在就做所有这些，后果在某些方面仍然会持续，因为它们是过去设定的。所以以你的理解，作为一名心理学家和环境学者，知道这一切变化仍然可能发生，这相当可怕。但我们是在减轻未来的变化，所以你对此有什么看法？我想你是对的。这绝对会导致，
contributes to the sense of helplessness that people feel because you feel like, oh, it's already, there are already going to be, the climate is already changing and there's already going to be more changes. So I can't do anything. I think we need to emphasize more strongly the difference between, you know, one amount of change and another amount of change. The Intergovernmental Panel on Climate Change released a report in October that delineated
助长人们感到的无助感，因为你觉得，哦，它已经……气候已经在变化，而且已经会有更多的变化。所以我什么也做不了。我认为我们需要更强烈地强调一种变化量和另一种变化量之间的区别。政府间气候变化专门委员会在十月发布了一份报告，描绘了
the difference between what if the temperature goes up by 1.5 degrees Celsius versus 2 degrees Celsius and identified a really big gap in impacts of 1.5 versus 2 degrees. So even though I think we have to acknowledge that climate has already changed, is already changing and will continue to change, there's still a lot of difference we can make in terms of the amount of that change and a difference that is going to make a difference in how we experience it. So there's still time to make changes. You know, it's not, even though we can't prevent everything that's been set in motion, there's still a lot of opportunities to mitigate the effects.
如果温度上升1.5摄氏度与2摄氏度之间的区别，并确定了1.5度与2度影响之间的巨大差距。所以即使我认为我们必须承认气候已经改变，正在改变并将继续改变，我们在那种变化的程度上仍然可以做出很大的不同，这种不同将对我们如何体验它产生影响。所以还有时间做出改变。你知道，即使我们不能阻止所有已经设定的事情，仍然有很多机会来减轻影响。
Absolutely. And I, you know, I mentioned the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate Change. which I'm sure some people are familiar with, you know, an international body of people that have produced reports on the evidence for and impacts of climate change. And I'm an author on the next report, they produce reports periodically, and I'll be participating in the next one. It's a huge and very serious body, and they wouldn't be doing this if they thought it couldn't make any difference. They're really doing this to provide the information that can guide public
绝对是这样。而且，我提到了政府间气候变化专门委员会，我相信有些人很熟悉，这是一个国际机构，制作了关于气候变化证据和影响的报告。我是下一份报告的作者，他们定期制作报告，我将参与下一份。这是一个巨大且非常严肃的机构，如果他们认为这不能产生任何影响，他们就不会这样做。他们这样做确实是为了提供可以指导公共
policy and choices that will affect the kinds of future we face. And I want to touch on people who are climate change deniers. Can you talk about the psychology of denial? I'm sure that's a very fascinating topic to get into. It is kind of fascinating. And a sad thing is that there are many, many reasons to be a denier of climate change. And to be honest, at some level, we're all deniers because if we really thought that it was as big an issue as it is, if we really took that to heart, we would be acting differently. And I include myself in that group. You know, I certainly use a lot of, I produce a lot of carbon emissions. It's a very hard thing for us to come to terms, because at some of it's hard for us to believe that we as a species can affect the environment,
政策和选择的信息，这些将影响我们面临的未来。我想谈谈气候变化否认者。你能谈谈否认的心理学吗？我相信这是一个非常迷人的话题。这确实有点迷人。可悲的是，有很多很多理由成为气候变化的否认者。老实说，在某种程度上，我们都是否认者，因为如果我们真的认为这是一个像它看起来那么大的问题，如果我们真的把它放在心上，我们会采取不同的行动。我把自己也包括在那个群体中。你知道，我确实使用了很多，我产生了大量的碳排放。这对我们来说是一件非常困难的事情，因为在某种程度上，我们很难相信我们作为一个物种可以影响环境，
you know, the whole global environment. It's hard to believe that. There are some groups for whom that's really hard to believe. For example, some colleagues of mine from anthropology and biology studied the Amish community. And the Amish can't really accept climate change because they just don't think humans can, you know, God is in charge of the world. Humans can't affect the world. And there are other religious communities that might also feel the same way.
你知道，整个全球环境。很难相信这一点。有些群体对此真的很难相信。例如，我的一些来自人类学和生物学的同事研究了阿米什社区。阿米什人不能真正接受气候变化，因为他们只是不认为人类可以……上帝负责世界。人类不能影响世界。还有其他宗教社区可能也有同样的感觉。
So we have these sort of ideological beliefs that make it difficult for us to acknowledge this is happening. And we want to justify the system we live in as opposed to say, well, this is not working. We need to, you know, start over. That's very difficult. Of course, we also, to the extent that climate change is scary, and it is scary, you know, we're trying to protect ourselves by denying it, so to maintain positive emotions. And then, of course, it has to be acknowledged that in the United States in particular,
所以我们有这些意识形态信仰，使我们难以承认正在发生的事情。我们想证明我们生活的系统是合理的，而不是说，好吧，这行不通。我们需要重新开始。这非常困难。当然，在气候变化很可怕的程度上，它确实很可怕，我们试图通过否认它来保护自己，以保持积极的情绪。当然，必须承认，特别是在美国，
as well as some other countries, climate change has become really politicized. So it can be a marker of group identity to say you do or do not believe in climate change, regardless of what you might truly think. So I think that that political identity gets in the way of people just addressing the issue as an issue. Right. I mean, you know, when people deny climate change, do you think they're sort of just, do you think it is more motivated by politics? Or you said, like, just people are just, they'll believe that I'm not seeing this in front of my face. You know, I'm not seeing, you know, the lake freezes every winter or like this polar vortex.
以及其他一些国家，气候变化已经变得非常政治化。所以说你相信或不相信气候变化可以成为群体认同的标志，无论你真正怎么想。所以我认为那种政治认同阻碍了人们仅仅把这个问题作为一个问题来解决。对。我的意思是，当人们否认气候变化时，你认为他们更多是受政治驱动吗？还是你说的那样，人们只是不相信我没有亲眼看到。你知道，我没有看到湖泊每年冬天结冰，或者像这种极地涡旋。
That was a common thing that came up. You know, this, these deep freeze. Like, okay, how can the world be warming if it's, if we're having these. extreme cold temperatures. That's right. And we of course, you know, it's easy for us to try and understand something in concrete terms in this very abstract issue of climate change. So right now it's snowing outside my window.
这是一个经常出现的问题。你知道，这种深度冷冻。好吧，如果我们有这些极端寒冷的温度，世界怎么可能变暖呢？没错。当然，我们很容易尝试用具体的术语来理解气候变化这个非常抽象的问题。所以现在我窗外正在下雪。
And we did have really cold temperatures last week. So that's some really concrete evidence that doesn't seem consistent with global warming. It's very hard for us to really wrap our minds around things like, well, but on average, We have these different movements of, you know, air currents and, you know, there's these, the glaciers seem to be melting a little bit faster than usual. Those are really hard for us to kind of grasp and take seriously. Is it possible to change the mind of a climate change denier? I would say yes, and I certainly hope so. But my first response would be, I'm not sure that should be our strategy.
上周我们确实有非常寒冷的温度。所以这是一些非常具体的证据，似乎与全球变暖不一致。我们很难真正理解像“但是平均而言，我们有这些不同的气流运动，冰川似乎比平时融化得快一点”这样的事情。这些对我们来说真的很难掌握并认真对待。改变气候变化否认者的想法有可能吗？我会说是的，我当然希望如此。但我的第一反应是，我不确定那应该是我们的策略。
And one reason I say that is that, you know, people resist having their mind changed. So it sounds like you're giving in, you know, you're losing in the persuasion battle at some level. So when you say to somebody either explicitly or even implicitly, I'm going to bring you over to my way of thinking, you're requiring them to give ground at some level. So I would say instead of kind of focusing on, oh, you have to accept climate change, like, Let's focus on the actions. What is it that we want people to do? Do we want them to support higher fuel efficiency standards? Let's focus on some of the reasons for doing that and not require them to accept climate
我这样说的一个原因是，人们抵制改变他们的想法。所以听起来你是在让步，你在某种程度上在说服战中失败了。所以当你明确或甚至隐含地对某人说“我要把你带到我的思维方式中”时，你在某种程度上要求他们让步。所以我建议不要专注于“哦，你必须接受气候变化”，让我们专注于行动。我们希望人们做什么？我们希望他们支持更高的燃油效率标准吗？让我们专注于做这件事的一些原因，而不是要求他们先接受气候
change first. There are lots of what have been called co-benefits to addressing climate change. So sort of basically side effects that will have positive impacts on people. And a lot of those might have to do with energy efficient. and saving money. Yeah. A lot of them have to, a lot of them have to do with health as,
变化。有很多所谓的应对气候变化的共同利益。所以基本上是会对人们产生积极影响的副作用。其中许多可能与节能和省钱有关。是的。其中许多与健康有关，
you know, as a species. There would be a lot of benefits for us in, you know, driving less and eating less red meat and walking more and, you know, reducing our air pollution so that we weren't exposed to such air quality that leads to respiratory disorders.
作为物种。如果我们少开车、少吃红肉、多走路、减少空气污染，使我们不暴露在导致呼吸系统疾病的空气质量中，这对我们会有很多好处。
So there are a lot of positive reasons to get people to engage in these climate protective behaviors. But motivating change is obviously always difficult. Yes. And I didn't want to totally ignore your question about changing the minds of climate change deniers. So there are some ways to make the message more effective. And a couple of things that might specifically relate to their motives for denial
所以有很多积极的理由让人们参与这些气候保护行为。但激励改变显然总是困难的。是的。我不想完全忽略你关于改变气候变化否认者想法的问题。所以有一些方法可以使信息更有效。有几件事可能特别与他们否认的动机有关，
or to make sure that the messenger, the person who's delivering the climate change message, somebody they trust. So somebody who might be seen as a member of their own group as opposed to an outsider who's trying to again to force their own position on them. And another is that you can tie it to values that they endure. So, you know, there's psychological research looking at how conservatives and liberals on average tend to endorse slightly different sets of values. So if you're talking to a more conservative group, you might emphasize the values that are more important to them. And to a liberal group, you emphasize those different sets of values.
或者确保信息传递者，即传递气候变化信息的人，是他们信任的人。所以可能是被视为他们自己群体成员的人，而不是试图强加自己立场的局外人。另一个是你可以把它与他们珍视的价值观联系起来。所以，有心理学研究观察保守派和自由派平均倾向于支持略有不同的价值观。所以如果你在和一个更保守的群体交谈，你可能会强调对他们更重要的价值观。对于一个自由派群体，你强调那些不同的价值观。
And I think you can come up with climate change messages that are really targeted towards a particular audience. And I want to talk about your other research, which focuses on understanding and promoting a healthy relationships between humans and nature. And so you done a lot of research at zoos. how do zoos help people feel more connected to nature? Well, you know, this is something that I just fell across and it hadn't, it didn't occur to me until I happened to be talking to some people who worked at zoos. So like everybody else, I went to a zoo as a child and then I took my children to the zoo, but I didn't think of it much other than that.
我认为你可以提出真正针对特定受众的气候变化信息。我想谈谈你的其他研究，该研究侧重于理解和促进人类与自然之间的健康关系。你在动物园做了很多研究，动物园如何帮助人们感到与自然更亲近？嗯，你知道，这是我偶然发现的，直到我碰巧和一些在动物园工作的人交谈时，我才想到这一点。所以像其他人一样，我小时候去过动物园，然后我带我的孩子去动物园，但我没有多想。
But talking to the zoo researchers, I realized that for many people, the zoo is a place to encounter the natural world. And it's one of the few places where they can do that. And zoos really attract a very broad, you know, range of people. Many zoos will have, you know, free days so that money is not a barrier. Many, many children will go in school groups. So a lot of people go to the zoo. And Bob Chaldeini once said, you know, if you're a social psychologist, you should go where the people are.
但与动物园研究人员交谈后，我意识到对许多人来说，动物园是一个接触自然世界的地方。这是他们可以这样做的少数几个地方之一。动物园确实吸引了非常广泛的人群。许多动物园会有免费日，这样金钱就不是障碍。许多孩子会以学校团体的形式去。所以很多人去动物园。鲍勃·查尔迪尼曾经说，如果你是一名社会心理学家，你应该去人们所在的地方。
So I thought, well, I'll go where the people are. And then their social situations. So people are not just individuals going and looking animals. They're people going in groups to look at animals and then sort of react to those animals in groups and give each other messages about how do I feel about this animal. And, you know, what is what is our relationship with these animals? And then, you know, finally, zoos have a mission. They do think of themselves as conservation organizations. So they are trying to deliver messages to people that encourage them to kind of feel a more supportive relationship with the natural world.
所以我心想，好吧，我会去人们所在的地方。然后是他们的社会情境。所以人们不仅仅是个人去观察动物。他们是成群结队地去看动物，然后在群体中对这些动物做出反应，并互相传递关于“我对这只动物感觉如何”的信息。你知道，我们与这些动物的关系是什么？最后，动物园有使命。他们确实认为自己是保护组织。所以他们试图向人们传递信息，鼓励他们对自然世界产生更支持的关系。
And overall, did you feel like people's who you interviewed and you studied, do you feel like that did increase their connection to nature by being at a zoo? Yeah, some of the research definitely has suggested that. and I often you know there are people who are critical of zoos and you know for some legitimate reasons and my response is always so I don't have to have a philosophical position on zoos I'm just studying the reality of zoos but also there's kind of an empirical answer which is do people who go to zoos care less about animals because they're being objectified and you know restrained or do they care more about animals and I have consistently found that people in zoos seem to care more about animals. So empirically, the zoos seem to be having that positive effect.
总的来说，你觉得你采访和研究的人，你觉得去动物园确实增加了他们与自然的联系吗？是的，一些研究肯定表明了这一点。我经常……有些人对动物园持批评态度，出于一些合理的理由，我的回答总是，我不必对动物园持哲学立场，我只是在研究动物园的现实，但也有一个经验性的答案，即去动物园的人是否因为动物被物化和限制而更不关心动物，还是他们更关心动物？我一直发现动物园里的人似乎更关心动物。所以从经验上讲，动物园似乎正在产生那种积极的影响。
And what else can people do to feel a greater connection to the environment? Well, I think that we are not necessarily socially encouraged to feel that connection. So I think we need to be very deliberate about taking time. out from our lives to feel connected. I think, for example, when I was, you know, picking a college or picking a graduate school, the idea that I would pick a particular place was almost would be, was seen as illegitimate. You know, I should go on the basis of the program and the offerings and not on whether I like the campus.
人们还能做些什么来感受到与环境更紧密的联系？嗯，我认为我们不一定在社会上被鼓励去感受那种联系。所以我认为我们需要非常刻意地从生活中抽出时间来感受联系。例如，当我在选择大学或研究生院时，我选择一个特定地方的想法几乎被视为不合法。你知道，我应该根据项目和提供的课程来选择，而不是根据我是否喜欢校园。
And I'm not saying people should pick a graduate school based on their campus. But I do think that we, we can be encouraged to pay a little bit more attention to the actual place in which we find ourselves. And then how to incorporate more nature into that place. So I'm fortunate that I'm on a campus that has lots of trees. They have qualified as a tree campus and really put a lot of effort into making it look attractive. If you're at a place which doesn't have those advantages, maybe there are ways in which it could be tied to nature a little bit better.
我并不是说人们应该根据校园来选择研究生院。但我确实认为，我们可以被鼓励多关注我们所处的实际地方。然后是如何将更多的自然融入那个地方。我很幸运，我在一个有很多树的校园里。他们有资格成为树木校园，并确实在使其看起来有吸引力方面投入了大量精力。如果你在一个没有这些优势的地方，也许有办法可以更好地将其与自然联系起来。
You know, if you have an outdoor space, maybe there could be more shrubs or more flowers. Because, of course, people really do benefit from those moments that they spend in nature. Does it also help to bring nature inside the home, like houseplants or, you know, potted flowers, that kind of thing? Yes. And I think one of the questions that is currently being investigated is how much nature do we need? What's the dose response relationship here? We don't know the answer yet, but there's certainly research evidence suggesting that just having potted plants around, sometimes even posters of nature can be helpful. So, yeah, do whatever you can.
如果你有户外空间，也许可以有更多的灌木或更多的花。因为当然，人们确实从他们在自然中度过的那些时刻中受益。把自然带进家里，比如室内植物或盆栽花卉，也有帮助吗？是的。我认为目前正在调查的问题之一是我们需要多少自然？这里的剂量反应关系是什么？我们还不知道答案，但肯定有研究证据表明，仅仅在周围放盆栽植物，有时甚至是自然海报也会有帮助。所以，尽你所能去做吧。
And the research does show that when you're in nature, you do feel more connected to nature. And over time, hopefully that becomes a lasting or at least a semi-permanent sense of yourself. And hopefully people become better stewards of the environment through that connection. Absolutely. People who feel more connected to nature do tend to want to take care of it. It feels more personal to them. Like they're not being asked to sacrifice for something they don't care about, but they're being asked to, they're being invited to have a more positive relationship with something that's important to them.
研究确实表明，当你身处自然中时，你确实会感到与自然更亲近。随着时间的推移，希望这会成为一种持久或至少是半永久的自我意识。希望人们通过这种联系成为更好的环境管家。绝对是这样。感到与自然更亲近的人确实倾向于想要照顾它。这让他们感觉更个人化。就像他们不是被要求为他们不关心的东西做出牺牲，而是被邀请与对他们重要的东西建立更积极的关系。
And you also research environmental justice. Can you talk about what that is? Yes, there are, I would say a couple of ways of thinking about environmental justice. It's often used very specifically to refer to the idea that we need to make sure that environmental costs and benefits are distributed fairly. So there's a long history of environmental injustice in this country and around the world where numbers of minority groups, for example, tend to live closer to toxic. waste dumps and polluted areas. They tend to be further removed from, you know, happy, healthy natural environments, you know, parks and so on. So we really need to be mindful of the idea that that's one way in which injustice occurs is by exposing people to these environmental harms
您也研究环境正义。能谈谈那是什么吗？是的，我想可以从几个方面来思考环境正义。它通常被非常具体地用来指代我们需要确保环境成本和收益得到公平分配的理念。因此，在这个国家和世界各地，环境不公正有着悠久的历史，例如，少数群体往往居住在离有毒废物堆和污染区域更近的地方。他们往往离令人愉悦、健康的自然环境（如公园等）更远。所以我们确实需要注意这样一个事实，即不公正发生的一种方式就是让人们暴露在这些环境危害中，
and not giving them equal access to the environmental benefits. Then I've also been interested in, And because justice has been one of my research interests, you know, throughout my career, I'm interested in how people think about justice when it comes to environmental issues. They tend to conceptualize it in particular ways as opposed to the way in which they might think about justice in the workplace, for example. So how do they think about justice and how do their perceptions of justice influence the way they respond to environmental issues? And do you have any other research that you're working on right now?
并且不给予他们平等的环境收益获取权。此外，由于正义一直是我整个职业生涯的研究兴趣之一，我也一直对人们在面对环境问题时如何思考正义感兴趣。他们倾向于以特定的方式来概念化它，这与他们思考工作场所正义的方式不同。那么，他们是如何思考正义的，他们的正义观又是如何影响他们应对环境问题的方式的呢？您目前还有其他正在进行的研究吗？
Well, right now I'm focusing primarily on two things. One is I developed a scale a number of years ago, maybe 15 or maybe more, maybe more, to measure what I call environmental identity, which is that sort of lasting perception of oneself as being connected to an interdependent in the natural environment. And so that scale has been white. widely used and right now I'm working with a number of people to see if we can validate it cross-culturally and with a number of different samples because I did develop it primarily
嗯，目前我主要关注两件事。第一件事是我在多年前，也许是15年前或更久以前，开发了一个量表，用来衡量我所说的“环境认同”，即那种将自己视为与自然环境相连并相互依存的持久自我认知。这个量表被广泛使用，目前我正与一些人合作，看看我们能否在跨文化和不同的样本中验证它，因为我最初开发它时主要针对的是
with college students. And then the other thing I'm working on is really trying to explore something we touched on earlier that distress and anxiety people feel when they think about climate change even though they might not have directly experienced negative impacts. Yeah, I'm sure they'll be very fascinating what your findings are. Yeah. Yeah, there's definitely a big, there's a lot to explore there. And the students you teach, what are, what attitudes about the environment do you see,
大学生。另一件事是我正在尝试探索我们之前提到的内容，即人们在思考气候变化时感受到的痛苦和焦虑，即使他们可能没有直接经历过负面影响。是的，我相信您的研究结果一定会非常引人入胜。是的，确实有很多值得探索的地方。那么您教的学生，您看到了他们对环境有什么样的态度，
see with the younger generation? Well, of course, there's a, I think there's a perceived to be a socially correct response. So they know that they're supposed to care about the environment. But I think most of them actually do, and especially, as I say, at my campus where we have this nice environment. People say sometimes they came here because they really like the look at the campus. So very much people are concerned about the environment. I do sense a fair amount of hopelessness, not quite what I would call despair, but just a pessimism. So that's a general response.
在年轻一代身上看到了什么？嗯，当然，我认为存在一种被认为是社会正确的反应。所以他们知道他们应该关心环境。但我认为他们中的大多数人确实很关心，尤其是正如我所说，在我们拥有这种优美环境的校园里。人们有时说他们来这里是因为他们真的很喜欢校园的样子。所以人们非常关心环境。我确实感觉到了一种相当程度的无助感，虽然还称不上绝望，但只是一种悲观情绪。所以这是一个普遍的反应。
Certainly there are a lot more, there are a lot of students. who are taking action and getting energized to respond as well. So these two things kind of coexist. One message I try to give is that the potential benefits of getting involved, I think that we all are looking for a source of meaning in our lives. And, you know, it's an opportunity in a way to be faced with this very global issue. and be able to join with other people and try to do something to address it. Well, thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Clay, and it's been a really great conversation.
当然，也有很多学生正在采取行动并积极响应。所以这两种情绪是并存的。我试图传达的一个信息是，参与其中带来的潜在好处，我认为我们都在寻找生活中意义的来源。而且，这在某种程度上是一个面对这一全球性问题的机会，能够与其他人联合起来，尝试做些事情来解决它。好的，非常感谢您加入我们，Clay博士，这是一次非常棒的谈话。
Well, thank you. It's been my pleasure, and I'm happy to know that people are interested in talking about this topic. If you've been a longtime listener or are new to our podcast, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes, or if you have time, write a review. We'd really appreciate it. Also, we'd like to hear from you directly, as I mentioned at the top of the show. So if you have any questions, comments, or ideas for us, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes the podcast
嗯，谢谢。这是我的荣幸，我很高兴知道人们对讨论这个话题感兴趣。如果您是我们的长期听众，或者是我们播客的新听众，请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分，或者如果有时间，写一篇评论。我们将不胜感激。此外，正如我在节目开头提到的，我们希望直接收到您的反馈。所以如果您有任何问题、评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至K-Luna@APA.org。即K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。Speaking of Psychology是APA播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括播客
APA Journal's Dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find our podcast on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingof psychology.org to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
APA Journal's Dialogue（关于新的心理学研究）和Progress Notes（关于心理学实践）。您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们的播客。您也可以访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的Caitlin Luna。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。